El hombro de Biden surge en un período.
real para una posible subida negociada
del conflicto
Creo que este hombro Brewster es el mejor.
un insulto calculado por parte de Biden
tiene entonces tiempo en ser uno de los
improvisación para la cual buydens
bianconi con sitio cerca de la casa
blanco
Sigue siendo importante en el spa de labios sucios.
entonces tienes que servir un serio obstáculo de pared para el
negociación y regalar esto
La situación es difícil y triste y es un rincón.
rania parte de la critica seca
sawai del bidente ami un poco religioso
que entonces todo para entrar estaba encendido
Nichols en Irak sostiene que la autoridad moral es
Fue inmediatamente disparado desde la carne de hierro un
cena putin haz un ejercicio de la
revisión de la política de guerra los
últimos ios
menos claramente
del alcance de la guerra en Irak para el mejor
Damián un error porque basado en
información diente renzi a los militares que
resultó arkin al falso aunque es mucho
diferente a lo que está pasando e
andre rusia y ucrania
muchos ios la invasion de lucia la
nación de la península de crimea y lo
extensión
de la población es ahora un verde de la
guerra que prácticamente usarla
civil es como el blanco del sat
hackers para diferenciar y mismos los
estados unidos garza de tubos y pensó en
error comi rac1 significa preguntado
En esto desconciertan la invasión de Ucrania.
momento y que papel sea capaz de curar el
presidente francés emmanuel macron ento
Tuviste que profesor negociaciones con Rusia.
para pasar con el verano
el presidente macro por supuesto tiene
encontre a muccio y nene se escucho
durante su última semana conozca
sitio como cabeza de puente del
diplomacia europea
sin embargo
está cantando sobre
gansu bryar el tamaño europeo como
presidente del consejo de europa
el saber muy tenso que la finca metas
promedio si eres
entró de
aumentar para mejorar
desestabilizar una relación personal
como líder ruso
Últimamente completado y activo.
Bajos creados para el ascenso del poder.
de también la marca de alemagna y ne
siempre pasado eso fue explica mgr la
interlocutor de putin con el sindicato
Unión Europea tiene para que la marca macro sea la
intentando y ocupar y lugar
del marcador
sostiene el doble y se estira lo suficiente con
Rusia